you know there's no reason to watch the
game when you have
access to magic johnson's twitter
account as someone pointed out last
night who needs the associated press
either for a game review lamar jackson
proved why he was named mvp of the
league last year he came out of the
locker room after being injured
went on a game-winning drive and put his
team in a position to win justin tucker
hit the field goal to seal the win
thank you texting somebody is he texting
like family member or like like a cousin
and giving them an update and he just
doesn't realize he's on twitter
like he's just like hey this is what
happened in the game you're driving in
the car this is what's going on
what is up with him in these tweets it's
hilarious
yeah uh it's and and uh it's great i
love it
it adds to everything and now anytime
there's a huge moment in sports you can
count on
lebron james chiming in with emojis
and and all caps and exclamation points
and magic chiming in with a very with
the captain obviously
and and very calm and rational and
obvious summary of
of what occurred so uh thank you for
that irving magic johnson all right
playoff picture now that the ravens have
won to get to eight and five
look the good news for the browns is
this does not affect them they they
still are in great position to get in
they hold the five seed
and that loss still has them in control
of the five seat
the ravens have some work to do the
dolphins have some work to do
you know as we as we look at this
and when we consider the ravens now have
the jaguars giants and bengals
i i know you're you you you believe
there were flaws in the ravens game last
night
but i see them running this table don't
you
i i do too i do i mean
yeah i just don't i the giants
that defensive line maybe they can slow
down that running attack but i don't
know if i could sit there and look at
that giant's offense enough to go
okay it'll score more points than lamar
in that offense so
yes i'm with you you know the ravens
even though they're not playing like
great football
i do by far have the easiest schedule
here mike after that
who you liking your chances between the
raiders and dolphins
well the dolphins because they have one
more win frankly and and i think the
dolphins are a better team right now and
the raiders are in disarray we'll talk
about that coming up later i think
although the outline's been completely
trashed by last night's events the idea
that they got rid of paul gunther and
switched to rod marinelli three days to
go before their next game is not an
encouraging sign and with three games
left i don't know the defense is going
to be much better so i have more faith
in the dolphins
but i think the way it works out here
and and last night's game has influenced
me to the point where i've forgotten
things that i knew before the game
i think the dolphins just if they went
out they get it even if the ravens went
out
they've got the tiebreaker and the
ravens go home so
the ravens do need some help here they
need the dolphins to win one and we'll
see if they or lose one excuse me and
we'll see if they do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports